peut être cette année gîte le plus
important en fait l'amour
aujourd'hui brigitte est en rémission
d'un cancer du sein et comme à son
habitude elle aime à se retrouver ici
le nid gré par les amazones havre de
paix et de conseils pour les femmes
touchées par le cancer qu'est ce que
vous avez écrit beaucoup d'amour
brigitte accroche son voeu sur l'arbre à
souhaits bien d'autres femmes
franchiront la porte du nid aujourd'hui
ses portes ouvertes elles ont été près
de six ans depuis avril dernier sous
forme d'ateliers dé spécialiste en
sophrologie esthétique ou aux sports
aquatiques et les autres accompagné les
ont aidés à traverser l'épreuve du
cancer
je vais peut-être faire une opération
aussi j'ai déjà fait de la chimio
maintenant j'ai fait un opéra son décès
on sait pas contre mais je suis venu
pour un peu de chalon peu de bus confond
ils tous et puis comme je reçois
toujours des messages alors je viens
comme je peux déjà fait l'atelier de
yoga parce que je n'ai fait un depuis
des années je fais du yoga
donc j'ai fait l'atelier c'était super
qu'est-ce que vous à vous ça vous a
apporté
sam apporter un bien-être le mari tête
parce que la chimio fait perdre les
cheveux la diététique parce que
l'alimentation participe à la guérison
le make-up parce que le teint vire au
vert sont les ateliers les plus prisées
du nid et surtout offert on a eu la
chance d'avoir
des subventions donc de l'agencé
régionale de la santé
donc qui nous permet de mettre en place
certaines actions
la vente de notre magazine magazine la
sortie pour octobre octobre rose
donc ça aussi ça nous permis ça nous a
permis de récolter des fonds
maintenant il ya les dos rond il ya les
adhésions il ya des petites choses comme
ça qui font vivre l'association
quotidien entre l'annnonce du cancer
quelques fois maladroite les soins
douloureux
la peur de la récidive le concept du nih
a su répondre à une demande constante
à tel point qu'il devient trop petit les
amazones compte bien agrandir cette
année